حسنًا ، لقد تعرضت للتعذيب ، فقد
تعرضت للتحرش
الجنسي وأشرف على ذلك كبير مستشاري
ولي العهد الأمير محمد بن حمد
القحطاني الذي كنت تعرفه بالفعل
وهددها باغتصاب أختي
وقتلها وتقطيع جسدها إلى أشلاء وهذا كل
ما في الأمر.  كانت تعيش في ذلك
الوقت وحتى الآن كما لو أننا لا نعرف
أين هو ديل كاتانا ليس لدينا أي فكرة عن مكان
وجوده في الواقع هو الشخص الذي يجب أن
يكون في المحكمة اليوم ليس أختي ولكن هذا
الرجل ليس سوى رجل عصابات  صخرته
يرتدي بدلة ومع ذلك لا نعرف
أين يخبرنا عن التهم ،
أخبرنا عن آخر يوم في المحكمة
، بدأت المحاكمة في وقت سابق من هذا
الشهر ، ما الذي اكتشفته اليوم ، لذا فإن
ما طلبته أختي اليوم هو
لديها شهر آخر للرد على
التهم لأن الجلسة
الأولى بدأت قبل أسبوعين آسف
ولم يُسمح لها سوى
بساعتين لمقابلة
الممثلين القانونيين لمعرفة كيف
ستكون قادرة على الرد  على هذه
التهم وساعتين لا تكفي ،
تم القبض عليها لمدة 10 أشهر والآن بعد
10 أشهر لا يُسمح لها سوى
بساعتين
للرد عليها وللتمكن من الرد على التهم
التي تواجهها بياليك ، ما
هي بالتحديد  لقد
اكتشفت التهم لأننا
لم نكن نعرف على وجه التحديد لفترة طويلة ، لذا نعم ، فإن
معظم التحديات تتعلق
بنشاطها في مجال حقوق الإنسان مثل التعامل مع
هيومن رايتس ووتش والاتصال بهم
والاتصال بمنظمة العفو الدولية ،
فهذه هي التهم التي  إنها تواجه
إحدى التهم المتعلقة بالتقدم الفعلي
لوظيفة في الأمم المتحدة
لطفل ، لكن هذا رسم رسمي
يتقدم للحصول على وظيفة في الأمم المتحدة
وهذا ما هو مكتوب باللون الأبيض باعتباره
تهمة رسمية. صحيح صحيح نعم
هذا هو  المذكورة في قائمة التهم
التي تتقدم بها ، تقدمت بطلب للحصول على
وظيفة في الأمم المتحدة ،
هل اتصلت بك السلطات السعودية منذ أن بدأ كل هذا
تم القبض عليها.  (د) في مايو من العام
الماضي ، هل قالت السلطات السعودية أي شيء
لعائلتك ، أعلم أن والديك ما
زالا في السعودية على الإطلاق ، فليس لدينا
اتصال مع الحكومة السعودية
في الواقع ، لقد أرسلنا بالفعل رسائل لا حصر لها
إلى الحكومة دون أي
رد منهم ، لذلك نحن لا نفعل ذلك.  ليس لدينا أي
نوع من التواصل معهم نحاول
القيام به ولكن حتى الآن لم نتمكن
من القيام بذلك